- So, when did you decide
to give up teaching though
and just do comedy?
Was it, obviously, it
was always your dream?
- It was always my dream, and it was what
I was working hard at.
- Yeah.
- And I was already a young father,
and I had, my daughter was
already six months old,
and, you know, I lived an
hour outside of Manhattan.
There's Jenny right there.
And I was living an hour
outside of Manhattan
in my hometown of Long Beach, New York.
And it was a real
struggle to be able to get
to the clubs and then come back and so on.
And then my wife, Janice, we'll be married
51 years in June, said,
- Wow.
"I'm gonna go back to work.
(audience claps)
I'm gonna go back to work."
She had a really good job,
an assistant to the dean of theater
at a junior college on the island.
And we had health benefits, and she said,
"You know what?
You take care of Jenny all day.
I'll come home from
the school around 5:00,
hand her off, do whatever you have to do,
and go into the city
and become the comedian
I know that you can be."
And it was the greatest, greatest gift
of her selflessness as a young mother
with a six month old to trust me.
And I was Mr. Mom way
before it was popular.
You know, I was, so this was 1973
and a little bit, and it was really,
I look at it as a real
turning point in my life,
not only as a father,
but as a human being
- Yeah.
- because it gave me perspective
on what we're here for
and what you're responsible for,
and to love someone so
selflessly and take care of her
and make sure that she's
healthy and happy and educated.
And even in those early days,
and it forever bonded us.
I mean, it was a really great,
important time in my life.
- Wow.
And what an amazing, I mean, now I get,
congratulations by the way, 51 years,
that's insane
(audience claps and cheers)
in any environment, but especially
in the entertainment industry,
that's kind of unheard of.
So that's amazing, but I love,
I guess the lesson there
too is just the support was,
you know, always there,
and the partnership was always there.
Do you think that that's basically
how that, it's lasted so long?
What's your advice for
staying married 51 years?
- Have a girlfriend.
- Oh, you know what?
(Kelly and audience laughs)
- The thing is that Kelly, then we laugh.
We joke, we still learn from each other.
We still love being together.
This, you know, this year
was such a test of that.
I mean, I've been in this chair
since last March 12th basically.
(Kelly and Billy laugh)
And just, we just have so much fun
and keep discovering new
things about each other.
And I think that's the
most important thing is
to still always be curious
and find out more about each other.
- Yeah, oh, well, you are lucky.
That's a beautiful
relationship that you've had.